Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to The Park
now we're about to go in this witch's mouth
and I wanted to say that without sounding sexual in any way
and I think I accomplished my goal
so let's go charging in there
and go right down the gullet
now that I have a flashlight anyway
bedubabe
oh-hey! That's a new loading screen
and I didn't even know that we needed a loading screen
considering we've kind of all been fluid
so what's going on in the witch's mouth house?
mouth house, house mouth
mo-mouth house - oh
Is this where the nexus for dark energies is?
*mumbles* Ooh, is this where most of the scares are?
It's been pretty good about the scares
there's been a few things like Chad
wasn't too terribly scary, but...
I'm eager to see what else we got here
Ah, yes
Oooh, yes
Now I can't tell if it was all designed this way or if it's actually a reason for this.
*reads* "Done! Atlantic Park Island has closed its gates
A jeering throng of townsfolk gathered as we hung the heavy iron padlock on the gates
small minded fools scared of what they don't understand.
"My machines lie silent and dejected, but I am not beaten. I have sent my wife and son back to Boston--"
"--and I have retreated here, to the House of Horrors. I must think."
So your wife and your son don't think it's weird that you're hanging out in the House of Horrors
So you're wife and your son don't think it's weird that you're hangin out in the House of Horrors in your own custom little park here?
in your own custom little park, here.
Little bizarre...
little bizarre :P
HI CHAAAAD *remembers ex-boyfriend Chad*
Hi, Chaaaaad.
How you doin'?
How're you duin
What is-
Is that the Slenderman?
Is that the slenderman?
Tha-That is that's the slender man
Tha- that is the- that's the Slenderman!
Tha- that's is the Slenderman!
Tha-That is the slender man
Why is the Slenderman in here?
Why is the slenderman in here?
What is going on here?
what is goin on here?
OOOOOOOO
Ooooh, I like this.
I like this
I mean, I hope it's not just a cliche like that
I mean I hope it's not just a cliché like THAT
because the Slenderman had a bad habit of stealing children away as well.
Because the Slenderman had a baaad habit of stealing children away as well
also you look like the monstrosity that I met AND the person I met at the front gate
Also, you look like the monstrosity that I met, and the person I met at the front gate.
*creepy background noises*
thats bad sounds
That's bad sounds.
OOO
Ooooh
I like.
I like a lot - okay.
I like a lot
Then it - woah, hello!
WOAH HELLOOO?
That... that looks more like a werewolf-skin-rug than just a wolf-skin-rug.
Tha-that looks more like a werewolf skin rug than just a wolf skin rug
very bizarre
Very bizarre...
OKAY
Okay.
Carrying on.
Carrying ON
Ohh, oh! Callum! (Lorraine: Leave me alone!)
OOOH OOO
CALLUM
Leave me alone?
"Leave me alone?"
"Leave me alone?!"
Leave me alone?
Why did I come charging in after Callum if all I wanted is- *loud thud* hey...
why did I come charging in after Callum if all I wanted to SSSSSay
MWAHAHAHAHAHAHAHA
*staged maniacal laughing*
Oh, okay. It's gonne be like - wuh!
OH okay it's gonna be like...
WHA...What are your guns powered by?
What are your guns powered by?
Your own breath?
What is that?!
what is that
He's got- he's got breath-powered guns!
he's got.... he's got BREATH powered guns
I'm not even exaggerating! That's literally what they are!
I'm not even exaggering that's literally what they are. OKAY Byeee
Okay, byyye!
Uhhh... ohh! You're... very scary! Verryy scary.
Oh you're...VERY scary
VERRRY SCARY
Okay.
Hello. How am I lookin'?
Hello, how am I lookin
Oooh, I'm lookin' good.
OOOO I'm looking good
Also, my eyes look rather dead, and... barren, but...
Also my eyes look rather dead... and barron
Ruuuaaar... ruuuaaaaar!
RRRRRAAAARRRR
BRRRRRAARARRRR
Okay, goodbye!
okay, goodbye
*flickering noises* Ooh... oh. Huh. Well that's peculiar...
that's peculiar
How's it goin'?
How's it going
Is there going to be something to do with these reflections in here somewhere?
Is there gonna be something to do with these reflections in here somewhere?
Cause that looks... not fun.
Cause that looks, not fun
Hello~
Hi!
HIIII
Hookay...
okaaay
Alright...
Eugh. Oh God. *spooky background humming*
God, Im gonna see something behind me aren't I?
I'm gonna see something behind me, aren't I?
Helloooo
Hello~
How you doin'?
Nothing here? No, not worth reading? Okay.
nothin here, no not worth reading
*Long inhale* D'okay!
OKAAAY, apparently a whole lotta nuthin
'Parently a whole lotta nothin'!
Mmm...
Hello~
Okay...
*Loud thud* 'Eyyy - oh! CHAD!
OH CHAAAD
Gaddammit Chad!
GOD DAMMIT CHAD
Stop being a sack'o'shit and get out here!
STOP BEING A SACK OF SHIT AND GET OUTTA HERE
Come on now, Chad...
come on now chad
You know it'll take more than that.
You know it'll take more than that
Are you a nazi vampire or sumthin like that?
Are you a Nazi-vampire-something like that?
(Lorraine: Show yourself!)
Show yourself, Callum. (Callum: Look out!)
Oh, hello~
(Lorraine: *angry* What have you done with him?)
*mimicks* What have you done with him?
Huh.
Okay.
Can I get down there?
There's gotta be something to do with the mirrors!
Some reason there's so many mirrors- *strangely loud light turning on* oh!
Okay.
I mean, other than the fact that it is, indeed, a haunted house
which it is
I know it is
So, obviously they would have a lot of those- *loud thud accompanied by strange squealing*
*maniacal laughing* Okay... so it was back here, right?
Wasn't it?
It was under here.
Ah! There we go! Shadow!
Hello?
(Lorraine: *surprised* Who was that?)
*mimicks* Who was that?
Oh, gadammit, of COURSE! You sack of shit.
*Loud thud accompanied by maniacal laughing*
You didn't- you did- you didn't get me.
That's a lie.
You're a-lying, I'm lying.
Okay, OOH! Blood!
That is a- that is a conspicuous amount of blood.
Oh, no wait. That's not blood. That's just a broken floor, geez.
Oh!
*creepy singing* "One little duck went out one day..."
Okay, BYE!
I'm- I'm still confused.
I've had no intelligent commentary this entire time because I've been waiting eagerly for something to happen.
Yet, nothing really has...
Okay, I guess I just carry on... to follow.
Can you let me in?
Please?
Oh.
Is this his hidey-hole for the dark nexus of energy?
Euu...
Euu, okay.
(Lorraine: *whimpers* Show yourself.)
*mimicks* Sh-show yourself, maybe. I don't know if I want you to.
Hullo~
(Lorraine: *whimpers* I'm a horrible mother... where is he?)
*door shuts* I dunno. "Nightmare Circus."
"A circus burns to the ground on opening night, killing dozens. The owner is put to death by an enraged mob--
--of townsfolk. Just as he shouts out a curse, now raven, a dark souled wanderer, comes to the ruins--
--at dusk in search of his missing mother... let the show begin!"
Well, that's kinda the opposite of what's happening over here.
I'm wondering if that's intentional.
Wait, did you say 'Don'?
Wait, did I- did I mishear something there? Was that- she said that 'Don' was there
but I thought 'Don' was the name of her dead boyfriend?
*skims paper on-screen*
Okay.
Weird.
Wait, so thi- is this my house??
*skims title and summary on-screen*
Okay.
Little bizarre, but I-I-I'll... *trails off*
*mumbles* What's that?
Dentist?
I'm guessing.
Aww~
That's so sweet!
You can't be that bad of a mother!
It's a rubix cube, I could solve it!
Oh, man.
His hat - nothing on there.
It's just a bunch of his stuff.
It's, for some reason, in the bottom of this House of Horrors.
So, this must all be...
This must all be... in her mind.
"Examine a wrench?" Why do you need to examine a wrench?
Is there something over here?
Wait - what is that?
Ah, there we go.
*Markiplier gibberish, attempting to read the list*
Okay...
*whispers* Weird...
Okay!
I guess that's... perfectly normal. Nothing too weird about that...
It's so bizarre! This took a turn.
Like... thematically, it took a turn.
Going into this House of Horrors,
pacing wise, it changed all this stuff.
*reads sad note on screen*
So that's her mother
who, in this letter
is obviously a bit of a terrible person.
Because, you can't blame someone for growing up a certain way.
They are who they are.
That's horrible!
And she ran away!
She didn't even give a chance!
Oh, that's-that's-that's a terrible letter...
That's a terrible person...
*reads letter on screen*
Oooohhhhh...
So that explains the hospital and possibly the
you know, the electrocution.
If it was electro-shock therapy...
which, I don't even think is used anymore...
or it shouldn't be anyway...
Then, that's fascinating.
*reads text on screen*
*sarcasm* Yeah...
'Feel better, or else we'll shock you.'
I don't know if that's even remotely good.
Okay, soo...
So, she was on medication for depression.
Most likely, she tried to kill herself, at some point - I can't quite... figure it out though.
*reads text on screen*
Wow...
That is juuust REALLY shitty...
Man...
Oh, man.
People suck.
People just suck...
So weird-
Why is that door glowing?
(Lorraine: Leave me alone!)
*mocks* Leave me alone!
Why?
*suspicious* Who's laughing behind there?
Oh god!
It's a P.T. situation!
More pills?!
I don't know if I should even take those after what happened last time.
Oh, there's a teddy bear~
*reads paper on screen*
Aww, that's so sad...
*creepy radio-like growling* Euu...
Oh! Hi Callum!
(Lorraine: Don't leave me!)
Callum!
I-I see you!
Over there...
Let me see if there's any other notes.
Possibly...
Ohp, still there.
It's the same note.
Callum?
(*what sounds like Lorraine and Callum talking at once* Don't make me look at it!)
Okay.
Take the pills...
Follow up...
Organize babysitter...
man...
EUGh
What is going on on that radio?
( Lorraine: *whimpering* I'm a horrible mother... where is he?)
Hello, wine and spoiled food.
Ah, yiss, a good year.
Continuing on...
(Lorraine: *angry* Leave me alone!)
You are very confused, at the moment...
*creepy guy singing with Callum very slowly* "One little duck went out one day,"
"Over the hills and far away..."
*cringing mark*
"Mother duck said 'quack, quack, quack, quack'..."
"But no little ducks came back..."
Mark: Huh??
Uhh...
Okay, was that written by Callum?
Let's see... same notice as before, right? Okay...
*squeaking door* Euh...
I-I'm imagining this is gonna loop over and over again
and it's gonna get more and more...
depressing as time goes on.
*creepy guy talking* One little duck went out one day...
Mark: Sadder and sadder...
Oh, boy.
OHH, it's in disarray now! More bottles - more pills -
WOAH!
*creeped out* What the hell happened?
Oh, geez...
OH, geez.
( Lorraine: *angry* Where is my boy?!)
OH, GEEZ
OH, GEEZ!
OH, GEEZ! *creepy music playing backwards* Uh...
Uh!
Apples and Zoloft...
UH. Zolift, sorry.
Tickets to Atlantic Island Park
Okay, at least you remembered about that
even though this whole place is in disrepair...
(Lorraine: *fearful whimpering*)
Mark: Ehhhhuuu
Why is that in the fridge? Okay-
WHY IS THAT CAR ON FIRE?!
Why are they DYING?!
WHY ARE THEY ALIEN-ZOMBIES?!
Oh, geez, so many questions...
oh, no...
(Lorraine: *fearful whimpering*)
Mark: Oh, no...
Oh, no.
Oh, no...
*creepy voices and music coming from the television*
Heuh... okay.
Man, this game...
Just took a tuuuuurn...
Oh... HEY! It's-it's the guy!
Okay, but why?
And also, there's no door here anymore...
I'm guessing that was probably the final level.
Lorraine: *scared* Don't leave me!)
Cause I dou-*constipation noises*-there's more!
Ooooh, there is MORE!
Babies hanging from the cieling!
WOOOOO!
WOO, NELLY!
Hu-woo, nelly!
Wooo...
Baby got put in time-out over there.
WOO!
Baby got put to bed!
HOO!
Baby needs his diaper changed!
Hello~
Is that Don?
Oh, what a handsome feller.
*reads writing*
Ohh...
Oh...
Oh, baby- baby solved the rubix cube- woah
Side-ho?
What does that say?
Aba-say bye-bye
S-seh her- see her cry
See her try
See her lie
See her why- I du-eh...
*whining* I dunno what you're tryna say here!
Okay!
Alright!
Baby...
Little...
Black-eyes baby...
Eugh...
Oh! Baby head!
Oh, he needs a nap!
Oh...
Baby has a drinking problem...
Oh, baby's just tired.
Oh! Baby turned into Zolift.
Oh... man, there's a lot of babies.
*reads bottom of paper*
(Lorraine: *angry* Stop!)
Eugh.
Ohhh!
Baby for dinner!
Ohh, baby needs more time in the oven, apparently.
*door slam*
Is there a baby in here?
There's an ice pick.
Oh, no...
Oh, noo...
Is that bottles of blood?
Are th- are those bottle of blood?
Might be bottles of blood...
Okay, so I can't go through here.
Gotta go through this door.
Are there more babies over here?
There was a lotta-*door slam*
*dat face*
(Lorraine: *angry* Give him to me!)
*Footsteps coming from the other end of the door*
(Lorraine: *sad* Don't leave me!)
*Still footsteps, hence the sensual Mark face*
Uh-oh...
*door opening?* Woah... wait, which way?
(Lorraine: *sad* Don't leave me!)
*door creaking open*
Okay!
(Lorraine: *whimpering*)
Okay.
Oh, geez! *door slamming multiple times*
Hey, stop that!
You're letting in a draft!
Oh, boy. More babies.
Oh, babies!
Tryna avoid watching T.V.
Baby's just tryna get through the day...
Oh, boy! *Hush, Little Baby tune playing creepily in the background* Oh man...
Oh!
Babies for storage!
Heh...
Euh... *whining*
Oh, boy.
That's unsettling.
Unsettling, to say the least.
Is there another level to go down?
Another level?
Oh wait, hang on. Was there another part of the letter over here?
Uh, there was another letter, right?
No, apparently it's gone!
Or it's been-oh! It's been burned...
Oh, baby needs a cigarette. *Mark giggles*
Oh, baby had a long day at work.
Baby just needs a relax.
Huh...
*attempts* Alright...
Carrying down another level!
I'm sure this one's gonna go
*sarcasm* sooooo good.
Soooo good.
Hellooooo~
Ooh.
Even more.
Even more. My goodness...
Blood.
Where'd all the babies go?
All the babies seem to have been replaced with blooood...
Oh, no. There's blood on that.
That's not good.
What does it say now?
See her die- ask her why- see her try- see her lie- see him die
*creepy violin music* Well, that's a bi-OH!
*disgust* OHH!
Oh, HAI
OHH!
HEY!
WOO!
*creepy, dramatic music*
Oh.
Oh...
OHH!
HI
What is with that?
What is with that face? Ugh.
Kay, what am I...
lookin' at 'ere?
Oh, baby go- baby got overcooked.
Uh...
Uh, boy.
Oh!
*additional ambiance, similar to the high notes of a violin*
*gibberish* Somethin' gonna happen?
'You will watch me rot?' Eugh...
Okay...
Okay!
Alright!
All done?
All done? *traumatized*
OOHH! How lovely!
Huh...
I dunno!
Maybe! *reads text*
I don't think you were tickling 'im!
Eugh... *disturbed*
I think you were... MUUUUURDERING!
Is this where all the children have gone missing?
Ohh, that makes sense now.
That makes horrible, horrible sense.
Oh, 'Eyes without sparkle' I dunno what that means...
Oh, boy...
This is reaching a...
crescendo here.
'Examine book'- oh! We've reached a dead end! That's- that's good.
'Hansel and Gretel', of course. It's all come back to- *medium jumpscare sound*
So that's why it was so important that the tale in the
the-the-the swan lake thing
That's why it was so important that that's what it was.
Oh, no....
Oh, okay. God, that almost scared me.
Is this real? *confused*
Ah! Oh, stairs, can't handle 'em.
HI, CHAD!
Oh, good, a- a shirt of cthulhu.
Perfect.
Do I need to quick-time event here sometime soon?
NOOOO
N-NOOOOO
N-n-n-NO
How 'bout no? How about a whole lotta no?
Can I- can I- can I fight this?
Do I have a choice?
*dramatic, dark music*
*door opening*
*sad music playing*
*sad, finale music*
I don't knowwwww!
What. The hell. Was that?!
MAN!
*yelling* These games constantly leaving their endings open up to interpretation!
Ahh, come on!
*sigh* I'm trying to piece it together in my mind.
So, wh-what I'm confused by is
That guy at the end there, that was Mr. Winter, but was Mr. Winter really that?
She seemed to be in a police interrogation room
that seemed to be Mr. Winter
Atlantic Island Park
So, what's real?
That's the question that I have on my mind.
What is actually real here?
What's the truth?
What is the truth of the matter?
And what's just in her mind?
What is fake?
What's-what's-what-what is the thing that her mind has been led to interpretation, and what is the truth?
The truth of the matter is
I feel, at it's most basic,
She lost her boyfriend, Don
She lost Don. She had a child, Callum.
And she regretted that child.
Because that child was a burden on her life.
And I believe, I believe at the end of that, what it's trying to say is that she killed Callum.
SHE did.
And in that police interrogation room, she has said that she has lost her child
and that whole journey through the park was her
battling with herself, finding child, begging for him to come back.
In that she regretted her action, and yet, that is what she did.
That's my interpretation of what that is.
I may be wrong, but that's the only conclusion I can draw from, based on what it's showed me.
But, I DUNNO!
How true is that?!
What the park even a real thing?!
Maybe the park was a real thing
but, you know, she always regretted the park because it's where Don died.
*sigh* Man...
So, like...
I don't know what to make of it.
How close am I? Is there a right answer out there?
Has it been explained?
*depressed* Hah, what a wild ride...
I guess that's just the way it is at the park, so...
Anyway, that is the full playthrough of The Park. It's shorter than I thought it'd be, but...
MAN, that was a wild ride, so...
Uh, I need some time to process this, but
Thank you, everybody, so much for watching! Let me know what you think of it down in the comments below
and if you have a better interpretation of what this ending means
and what the STORY means
let me know.
I wanna hear the thoughts...
So, thanks again, everybody, so much for watching.
And as always, I will see YOU
in the next video!
Buh-bye!